on a aussi des idées à défendre on a
aussi des combats à mener on a des
choses à faire on a envie de faire
bouger les lignes tout simplement
bonjour je suis Arthur billot je suis
président des Jeunes Démocrates de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté parlez-moi ça je
suis aussi étudiant et en sciences
politiques j'ai adhéré au mouvement
démocrate à l'âge de 16 ans d'abord un
engagement européen ensuite celui-ci a
été complété par la logique libérale par
l'humanisme par finalement tout cet
engagement là qui qui prend corps en ce
parti plus largement réussi c'est aussi
un groupe d'amis c'est aussi un lien
social c'est aussi une logique
collective qui permet de de centrer sur
le terrain de découvrir son territoire
j'étais élu président des Jeunes
Démocrates de Brown Franche-Comté lors
de la convention régionale du MoDem qui
m'a d'abord intéressé dans dans cette
idée-là de reprendre cette fédération
c'est sûrement je pense de créer un
collectif un collectif de jeunes engagés
qui ont envie d'apporter quelque chose à
la cité pour ça on a plein d'esprit on a
une pluralité de talent à faire émerger
mais aussi à consolider moi c'est
d'abord voilà c'est logique assez
humaine qui m'a plu faut pas quand je
pense c'est logique humaine je pense
aussi logique humaniste il a plutôt
relève des idées on a aussi des idées à
défendre on a aussi des combats à mener
on a des quelque chose à faire on a
envie de faire bouger les lignes tout
simplement je pense que ce volontariste
est d'abord clé voilà il faut penser en
termes d'engagement en termes de
d'impact de militantisme au-delà de ça
on a aussi une fédération restructurée
on a des échanges qui arrivent assez
vite des engagements à prendre des défis
à relever une fédération des Jeunes
Démocrates pour moi fédération qui est
pluriel on doit pouvoir collaborer avec
les fédérations innées du modèle dans
tous les départements c'est à dire il
doit être une force de soutien on doit
être capable justement d'apporter de
l'aide quand on a besoin mais pas
seulement on doit aussi être un
collectif de jeunes qui s'engage qui
cherche aussi à accomplir certaines
choses à déverrouiller certaines
problématiques c'est justement cette
dualité qui est intéressant dans une
fédération de Jeunes Démocrates on a
d'une part l'engagement partisan au sens
vraiment local et en même temps on a ce
côté assez humain qu'on se retrouve tous
ensemble on prend des verres on partage
des moments ensemble et mis bout à bout
on arrive justement à une continuité un
engagement qui s’ancre sur la durée dans
lequel justement les gens
peuvent s'épanouir